Welcome back everyone this will be my brand new
house of the dragon game of thrones trailer video
of damon sitting on the iron throne i used it for
my thumbnail for another trailer video the other
day now this is obviously a much younger version
of the ronira character before she's been married
to damon or remarried to him throughout the main
timeline of the show a couple of the big players
wind up getting remarried within sort of the
different groups of the dance of the dragons
very spicy as you would expect from a game of
thrones show obviously one of the big ideas that
they try to get through in the trailer is that
damon targaryen views himself as his brother's
heir so viserys first targaryen is the king after
jaehaerys the first and they kind of deal with
that i think in episode one i think they'll get
through that pretty quickly i've already talked
about how they're doing the great council of 101
ac that council voted to make viserys the first
jaehaerys's successor so when we're looking
at young rhaenyra here and damon is sitting
on the iron throne this is a couple years later
in the timeline and viserys's wife has died and
he doesn't have a male heir and there's this big
question of succession obviously this is mostly
about the dance of the dragons this giant
targaryen civil war but that was actually
right to sit on the iron throne like bad kings
versus good kings bad queens versus good queens
alison hightower for example is a character that
gets compared a lot to cersei and i think that
that'll come through in some of the episodes now
she's not exactly like cersei it's not meant to be
a twin cessed situation or anything like that
it's more about her feeling like she has the
right to sit on the iron throne through her son
so to speak she doesn't have designs on the iron
throne the same way that cersei herself literally
put herself on the iron throne eventually as he
talks about this dream that he had you see the
footage of the tournament that's actually of
damon targaryen fighting a version of kristin cole
later in the timeline after he's gotten the dark
sister valyrian blade kristin cole is a member
of the kingsguard he eventually becomes lord
commander of the kingsguard after graham mctavish
who's the current version of the lord commander
under viserys the first before he dies so that's
why you see so many scenes of him with the older
version of alison hightower because that's after
she's been remarried to the king the really cool
detail in the trailer here is viserys the first
to telling the story about putting his hand on the
iron throne but you see blood on the throne here
that's because it's obviously made of thousands of
swords it cuts pretty much everybody that sits on
it within the continent of westeros there's this
rumor that goes around the nobles that anyone
who's not meant to sit on the iron throne the
throne will wind up eventually killing literally
so for instance joffrey got cut on the iron throne
a whole bunch cersei got cut a lot when she sat
on the iron throne literally and metaphorically
the stabbiest throne that you will ever sit on
when he talks about all the dragons roaring is
one obviously that's meant to be a metaphor for
all the targaryens roaring at each other during
the dance of the dragons like the story that he's
telling young ranira is meant to be a metaphor for
what'll happen in the future with the targaryens
roaring at each other over the battle for the iron
throne like it's not a good thing it's meant to
be a bad thing i believe the actual dragon that
we're seeing here is meant to be maraxxi's which
is rhaenyra's dragon most of the dragons that you
see in the trailer are meant to be bigger than
daenerys dragons while he's telling the story
you see the dragon flying over king's landing
to the dragon pit and it hasn't been ruined
like this is still a very intact version of the
dragon pit it was actually built by maegor the
first just a little bit earlier in the timeline
that was meant to be sort of the beginning of the
end for the targaryens like the minute they
started raising their dragons in captivity
in the dragon pit is the minute that they started
to slowly die off and get smaller and smaller
also didn't help that they had a civil war where
a bunch of the dragons wound up dying in battle
we see a little bit more of the city we see the
small council talking to viserys the first about
the matter of succession this is obviously earlier
in the timeline then eventually forcing him to
choose another wife but the whole idea is that he
doesn't want to choose an heir he doesn't want to
choose between his beloved daughter who he really
cares about and his brother who also has a claim
on the iron throne this is otto hightower this is
allison hightower's father he's obviously going to
be the person who probably suggests his daughter
become the next queen he's basically handed the
king through most of this period this is just more
footage that tournament of damon targaryen wearing
his dragon armor remember this is meant to look
kind of like rhaegar's armor later in the timeline
this scene of young grenier is with her first
husband layner velaryon father is actually on
the small council i believe at this part of the
timeline the sea snake on the small council is
the master of ships because house valerian is
basically like the most powerful seafaring family
in westeros they're also meant to be one of the
richest families in westeros at this time there's
a scene of damon targaryen wearing the gold cloaks
he actually created the gold cloaks he was captain
of the city watch so later in the timeline you
hear about the gold cloaks he's literally the
person that started that this is young rainer
with harold westerling that's grand mctavish's
character like i said lord commander during
this period in the timeline looking at the other
great houses the other members of the kingsguard
swearing filthy to her because the whole idea is
that you see this ceremony later where eventually
viserys the first picks her as his heir but then
eventually they force him to choose another wife
and then that wife becomes allison hightower she's
best friends with frenera when they're younger
but then obviously things deteriorate over time
because all the big factions here feel like they
have a stronger claim on the iron throne i believe
these two dragons are meant to be maraxis
and karaxis that's damon targaryen's dragon
and obviously ronira's dragon this is rhaenys
targaryen talking about rhaenyra's claim to the
iron throne being challenged i've already done a
couple videos about her in the great council of
101. she was the next in line for the iron throne
after king jahiris but the realm basically voted
against her and picked viserys instead so the same
question of who the heir is going to be winds up
happening later when rhaenyra is growing up i
love the way that she says knives will come out
and then like later in the timeline you actually
see the older version of allison literally coming
at renera with the valyrian dagger which they've
since confirmed is meant to be the cat's paws
dagger that eventually arya will use to kill the
night king obviously the dagger was also used to
start the war of the five kings too very important
dagger but when she's talking about knives coming
out the scene they actually put on top of this
is harold westerling pulling his sword out and
putting it on damon targaryen who's approaching
the iron throne because at this point in the
timeline it's before viserys has picked an air and
he still thinks that he is the strongest claim to
the iron throne this is just the scene later in
the timeline of viserys talking to damon about
how he's chosen rhaenyra to be his next heir but
that's before he's had a brand new son aegon ii
with queen allison there's a scene of dragonstone
you hear a dragon growling in the background
and you have the scene of the king's guard with
otto hightower hand of the king coming for damon
targaryen who looks like he's stolen the dragon
egg the woman with him wasn't his wife but she was
an advisor and a concubine what the scene might be
is him getting another woman pregnant and trying
to give that woman a dragon egg thinking that the
sun would eventually be raised as another dragon
rider like if it's going to be my son he's going
to be a dragon rider he's going to need a dragon
but the thing is is dragon eggs were probably
one of the most precious things to the targaryen
family because dragons were so precious so dragon
eggs were treated as more precious than gold
so if you were caught trying to steal a dragon
egg especially from dragonstone it was basically
treason this is just young ranira talking
to a younger version of kristin cole before
he's become lord commander even though there'll
probably be some comparisons to jaime lannister
he's not meant to be a golden trash bag like
jamie lannister is when they get older eventually
rhaenyra starts spending more and more of her
time at dragonstone so that's why you see a lot
of scenes of older rhaenyra inside the map table
room as they're doing a lot of battle planning
this is just another shot of her riding her dragon
all the scenes of this giant battle with the
dragons later in the trailer that you see are from
the same battle and it seems like it's going to be
the war of the stepstones that was against essos
against a force called the triarchy that's what
it seems like these people are here that's because
part of the battle was fought in this area in the
east of westeros like they literally call it the
battle of the stepstones because it took place
at the stepstones more footage of them showing
off an actual dragon egg is they're looking like
they're getting ready to actually hatch it like
they're heating it up getting ready to hatch it
this is a scene of damon targaryen cuddling
up with his giant red dragon karaxis
he's meant to be bigger than drogon just
for example so that's why he seems so big
she talks about inheriting the iron throne you see
the crown itself this is viserys the first's crown
and each time a new king was named sometimes
the crowns would change just a little bit like
they didn't always wear the exact same crown so
like this crown for instance you see a lot of the
sigils of the different great houses on it when
rainier is talking about allison blocking her
way she's talking about the dance of the dragon
she's talking to damon targaryen that's when
they eventually wind up getting remarried later
in the timeline this is kristin cole fighting
against the version of one-eyed aymond targaryen
a lot of targaryens on the show because it is
literally a civil war amongst all the targaryens
then the scene where you actually see allison
pull the valyrian dagger on older rhaenyra seems
like it's when the actual dance of the dragons
really sets off like the blacks and the greens
form their factions and start the actual fighting
then this final shot i think it's meant to be
maraxi's rhaenyra's dragon just because of the
way they position the other trailer footage where
you see the dragon head right behind her like
this is how big it's meant to be compared to her
much much bigger than daenerys dragons obviously